you call yourselves  legends time for a new  game i'm in the pipes  [Music]  get out of the way  [Music]  [Music]  eye on the sky  [Music]  [Music]  all yours darling you cannot advance the  current  [Music]  hey how's it going  remember me watch me  mirage really again what i'm a legend  [Music]  right  [Music]  i love whoever came up with this new  game  legacy of a champion cannot be measured  by simple victories  it is measured by resolve by commitment  to a single focus absolution  it is time to return the legends to  where it started  a little underground brutality  [Music]  that's a hell of a way to go when you  get to hell  tell him valkyrie sent you  welcome to the legacy of the apex  predators  welcome to the arenas  [Music]  you